Kristen Davis weighs in on the rumored
beef between Kim Cattrall and her and
just like that co-star Sarah Jessica
Parker saying she wishes she could fix
it they are allowed to have their own
feelings that's all I want to say in a
new interview with the telegraph Kristen
who's back as Charlotte in the Sex and
the City Revival series where's Samantha
oh um she's no longer with us tells the
outlet you have to respect people's
wishes I'm not gonna waste energy on it
I can't change anybody if I worried what
everybody in New York was saying about
me I never leave the house of course Kim
who played the iconic sex positive
publicist Samantha in the original
franchise has been involved in a long
public Feud with Sarah Jessica ever
since the series ended in 2004. a few
that seemingly revved up after Kim made
it clear she would not be returning for
the new series I think that the
character of Samantha will live forever
I love her so much but she lives in a
time and a place and I honor them and
Kristen she says she understands that
fans are upset adding I wish I could fix
it but I can't it's not in my power I
think what's wonderful is that we have a
writer and actors who love that
character who love telling stories and
being in situations and environments
with Samantha and we're really lucky we
have those memories in that experience
of course the show forged ahead without
Kim but left the door open for a
possible return we did everything we
could to honor Samantha who we love the
character and we know the fans love no
one could be another Samantha I think
Michael Patrick
sing it with respect and I feel that
that we have then in February 2022 SJP
told variety she would not be willing to
Star alongside Kim again saying I think
there's just too much public history of
feelings on her part that she's shared
listening to your instincts has been a
wonderful guide for me I have to get in
touch with what's right for me the cast
even told E.T that fans shouldn't hold
their breath for an appearance from Kim
in season two I think that Kim has made
it really clear that she's done and
we've heard her and just like that it
appears she had a change of heart
because Ed recently confirmed that Kim
will make a cameo in the season 2 finale
I always thought the four of us would be
friends forever
according to variety Kim shot one scene
back in March without interacting with
any of her former castmates and the
scene it involves a phone call with
sjp's character Carrie what I think
people love about shows like sex in the
city and just strong characters season 2
premieres on Max June 22nd and while
we'll just have to wait to find out what
that phone call entails fans can look
forward to the return of Patricia field
the original costume designer for Sex in
the City how it has influenced me with
color and splash and you know she always
says you're that sexy one so you know
let's see that in different ways to
express that and make that for that
particular character and it was such a
great pleasure to be to be dressed by
her because there's always something
unexpected
[Music]